[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle série de
vidéos consacrées à un outil très utile
pour les enseignants qui veulent
organiser des cours en dehors des murs
de la classe est ici nous sommes en
période de confinement avec le comique
19 et donc ça pourrait être un outil
très utile en ce moment on attend de
voir
il y a quatre vidéos consacrées à cet
outil et je vous êtes aujourd'hui dans
la vidéo qui va vous présenter les
fonctionnalités alayli
[Musique]
on a donc créé une réunion dans google
mythe comment faire pour la gérer tout
d'abord la première chose à faire est de
rejoindre cette réunion vous pouvez
simplement cliquer sur les liens que
vous avez créé la fenêtre s'ouvre deux
options se présentent à vous participez
à la réunion où présenter directement
il est toujours mieux de d'abord
participent à la réunion de telle sorte
salué les participants de celle ci le
premier menu dans lequel je souhaite
vous emmener est situé ici en bas à
gauche de votre écran dans présentation
et questions-réponses google mythe
ici vous allez avoir en fait tout ce que
vous avez mis dans l'agenda pour peu que
vous avez utilisé l'agenda pour créer la
google mythe
là je vous renvoie vers la première
vidéo qui a été réalisé par rapport à
cet outil
si vous l'avez créé par classe comme
vous n'aurez pas toutes ces informations
et donc c'est intéressant c'est que les
choses que vous avez pu mettre dans
votre agenda vont se retrouver ici comme
par exemple bien le contenu de la leçon
ce qui peut être aussi intéressant c'est
de mettre des pièces jointes donc la
gemmi aussi le premier tuto sur google
mythe que j'avais réalisé et qui vous
montre comment créer un google mythe
mais ce qui est surtout très intéressant
quelle que soit la façon d'opérer pour
créer la google mythe c'est ici les
liens vous allez retrouver toutes les
informations de connexion
aussi bien le lien que le code que vous
devez utiliser pour rejoindre google
mythe
vous pouvez bien sûr copier les
informations ici ensuite le second menu
est en haut à droite
et là vous allez pouvoir retrouver les
différents participants de la réunion
alors pour l'instant je suis seul mais
il ya également un chat très utile pour
noter ici les éléments les plus
importants on peut l'utiliser finalement
comme un tableau avec les mots-clefs
avec des ressources supplémentaires qui
pourra être consultée bien sûr chaque
participant peut interagir et il sera
intéressant que sur ce chat des
questions soient posées pourquoi parce
qu'il imaginait vous avoir une classe de
25 élèves dans lequel chacun va parler à
tour de rôle
ça va être ingérable donc on peut dire
aux étudiants de directement poser leurs
questions dans
chat et vous au fur et à mesure de les
exposer vous voyez les différentes
questions qui apparaissent ici
alors si vous avez des participants
malheureusement je n'ai pas ici vous
pouvez tout à fait couper le micro d'un
des participants
vous pouvez également l'exclure de la
réunion si il commence à faire n'importe
quoi
et donc ça c'est intéressant mais il
faut bien savoir qu'il y as uniquement
la personne qui a créé la réunion qui
pourra avoir ces fonctionnalités la
apparaître il ya bien sûr le menu ici en
bas dans lequel vous pouvez couper votre
micro
ce qui peut être très utile quand il ya
beaucoup d'intervenants on peut demander
à tous les intervenants de couper leurs
micros et donc celle là qu'ils devront
opérer
vous pouvez également coupé la webcam
mais continue à avoir le son et puis le
télé le petit téléphone rouge va vous
permettre simplement de quitter la
réunion
[Musique]
autre menu le menu des trois petits
points qui sont ici alors enregistré la
réunion va être très pratique parce que
vous allez pouvoir en acceptant
enregistré toute la réunion un fichier
vidéo sera créée et sera directement
ajouté dans votre google drive vous
recevrez une notification par mail vous
informant de la création de ce cette
vidéo
donc ça peut être intéressant quand on a
des élèves qui n'ont pas pu participer à
la réunion où des collègues qui n'ont
pas pu participer à la réunion ils
pourront se remettre à niveau ou des
personnes qui veulent revoir certains
passages de la réunion a bien ça peut
être fait par l'intermédiaire de cette
vidéo
dès que la réunion ait fini
automatiquement google va générer la
vidéo est aussi un google docs
c'est-à-dire un document qui reprendra
l'ensemble des échanges écrits qui ont
été faits sur le tchat ce qui peut être
intéressant si les élèves ont posé par
exemple des questions ou fait des
remarques ce mail vous a envoyés
automatiquement
mais en plus de cela si vous avez créé
la réunion à partir d'un évènement dans
l'agenda vous pouvez retourner sur cet
événement et la vidéo ainsi que le
document qui va reprendre l'ensemble des
échanges de jets vont être aussi
automatiquement intégrés bien sûr vous
les retrouverez également dans votre
google drive
donc il ya encore une fois plusieurs
possibilités pour retrouver ces précieux
documents
vous pouvez également modifier la mise
en page vous pouvez projetés en plein
écran activer les sous titres vous avez
les paramètres de la vidéo alors ce qui
est intéressant pour avoir une vidéo
très très fluide comme je le fais ici
c'est de choisir la résolution d'envoi à
720p si vous faites la résolution en
360p vous allez avoir une image qui va
être beaucoup plus saccadé regardez
c'est beaucoup moins élégant esthétique
donc toujours choisir ici le 720p pour
peu que vous ayez une bonne connexion
utiliser leur téléphone pour activer le
son vous pouvez
relais utilisés au téléphone en plus
signalé un problème et l'aide est ici
[Musique]
la dernière chose que je dois vous dire
sur google mythe et la présence de ce
bouton très importants présentés
maintenant dès que vous cliquer sur ce
bouton vous allez pouvoir présenter
l'écran qui est devant vous à tous les
participants de la réunion
vous pouvez choisir l'intégralité de
votre écran ou une fenêtre du navigateur
avec l'intégralité de votre écran vous
pourrez donc leur projeter directement
des sites web des documents word ou pdf
des présentations powerpoint ou google
slide bref tout ce que vous voulez
qu'ils se trouvent sur votre ordinateur
pourra leur être présentées attention
évidemment aux éléments plus intimes ou
aux photos personnelles qui pourraient
apparaître surtout si c'est en fond
d'écran
c'est du vécu dès que vous aurez appuyer
sur le bouton bien le participant verra
exactement ce que vous faites sur votre
écran
mais lui aussi possède cette possibilité
et il pourra vous présentait également
ses son écran si vous ne souhaitez plus
voir son écran présenté à l'ensemble des
participants via le menu participants
vous pouvez rejeté sa présentation est
donc à ce moment-là vous garantissez
quand même que personne ne vienne
perturber la présentation que vous êtes
en train de faire
dès que vous souhaitez interrompre le
partage de votre écran vous appuyez sur
arrêtez la présentation et vous revenez
à l'écran principal
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
votre soutien à ces vidéos
je vous souhaite un bon travail une
bonne prise en main de l'outil et je
vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]
il